this morning governments and businesses
are considering a way for people to
prove
they've been vaccinated against covet
19. they're called
vaccine passports and it could determine
who can travel
stay at a hotel or even visit a bar now
israel's already using them in the
european union just propose them
the u.s we're still thinking about it
roxanna sabiri's in london with more on
the story good morning to you roxanna
here's a question
what are the pros and the cons of this
idea
good morning gail while supporters say
it could help lift
lockdowns in cities like london you get
a shot you get a digital pass on your
phone
and then you can enter restaurants and
pubs but critics warn of the potential
pitfalls over privacy
and more the video
israelis must now scan in to get it
to gyms hotels even concerts
like this it is a
all set in the telephone it's very
convenient
for more than 3 million israelis and
counting
this is the ticket back to some kind of
normalcy
finally all the way in the car i think
back to
life back to reality
the government-issued green pass shows
personal details
and proves they've had two doses of a
covet-19
vaccine now countries across europe
and beyond are considering similar
so-called vaccine passports
or immunity certificates to inject life
back into a flagging tourism
industry and revive businesses and
hospitality
like pubs the uk is studying whether to
introduce vaccine certificates
raising the possibility that brits could
soon need a passport
for a pint yep all good we haven't had
stuff like this before we've never
thought in terms of having
something that you have to show to go to
uh you know a pub or theater
that and so there are deep and complex
issues
that we need to explore issues like
potential discrimination
against people who don't want shot along
with those who can't get one
for medical reasons or because there's
not enough supply
so these people won't be able to
participate in life
in public life in social life and
economic life in the same way
as their counterparts who have been
vaccinated
claire wenham from the london school of
economics says data privacy is another
concern
is it going to be something that's
that's digital and tracks you
and that obviously opens a whole
different range of conversations about
uh you know security of your data for
example so government shouldn't rush it
governments shouldn't rush it i think
it's a pandora's box and i think it's a
slippery slope into
you know having life being governed by
your health status
but as governments debate immunity
certificates businesses are pushing
ahead
some cruises and airlines for instance
say they'll require proof of inoculation
to board
so while these passes are raising tricky
ethical questions
you may need one to travel as early as
this year
the who tells cbs news it opposes
requiring vaccines for travel
as long as the global supply is limited
and their ability to stop the spread of
the virus is not yet
clear tony all right roxanna saber in
london for us roxanna thank you very
much
uh you know i love this idea i love it
too not everything is a slippery slope
sometimes you're taking one step forward
and that's all we get tracked digitally
all the time now for all sorts of things
i have no problem
yeah i also find guys the honor system
doesn't work here it doesn't
and normally if you don't get a vaccine
it doesn't affect me or you
yeah it normally just affects you alone
but that's right whether you get this
vaccine could affect a lot of people
everybody in that room and if you have a
medical condition that prevents
that from getting vaccinated if you have
an allergy i'm sure that can be worked
out and it can be marked on your
passport yeah
all right well no one's asked us but we
we approve so we're unanimous yeah where
are you
where'd you get your phd same place i
did right exactly
yes